if perhaps intentionally perhaps
accidentally they've put a list online
of countries
that in northern ireland will go on the
green list next wednesday at 4am and
because we're expecting a whole nation's
approach as we have had so far to the
traffic light system and the
restrictions around international travel
we are expecting
uh the rest of the uk to follow so as
expected malta
and the balearics go green from next
wednesday at 4 pm huge relief i'm sure
for the travel industry that have really
lacked a sort of major
british summer destination uh once uh
portugal went amber
uh three weeks ago a lot of caribbean
islands also going on to that
uh green list uh barbados
bermuda antigua and barbuda anguilla
um grenada um
so so caribbean islands some spanish
islands of course the belarus is
ibiza majorca menorca formentera
added to the green list and malta too
now some public health officials may be
slightly
concerned about ibiza in particular
because that attracts far
younger holiday makers and of course
those brits are unlikely to have had
two jobs but i think this will be huge
relief to the travel and aviation sector
that have been
pretty universally critical of the
government in recent weeks confusion
over this
uh system perhaps tonight we will have a
big rush of online bookings with travel
agents
and airlines to these destinations as i
say
the balearics uh probably the key
announcement there they are going green
but we'll have to wait until the uk
government give us the full picture
will there be as requested more details
over the metrics the data the maths
behind
the key decisions that the uk government
are
making and will there be any sort of
watch list as we were once
promised this sort of a danger zone of
countries that
are green but could be relegated to
amber or red
so and not particularly a clear picture
yet because
it has come as i say mark from the
northern irish executive not from the uk
government but it seems
clear so far that the belarus malta and
caribbean islands some key caribbean
islands will go green
another unknown we are expecting more
details
on uh advantages changes to the rules
from those
for those who have had two vaccinations
boris johnson and many cabinet ministers
this week have spoken so optimistically
about how
changes to the uh sorry progress of the
vaccine rollout should be reflected in
the easing of restrictions for
international travel what is the point
of getting
two jabs if it doesn't allow you to do
more and travel safely abroad so we are
expecting
more clarity from the government but
dates are so important
the travel industry know that as soon as
the school holidays start that is the
key time
to get people booking and to get money
spent if this only happens
towards the end of the summer it could
be far more difficult for them to
take advantage but just to recap one
last time the northern irish
executive saying that from next
wednesday at 4am
malta the belarus as well as some
caribbean islands going
on the green list we expect the uk
government to follow suit any second now